let's go to an international caller I
think let's go to the person who's
calling from country code 57 who's
calling from country code 57 hello it's
me that is you yeah what's your name
where you calling from
hi my name is also David and I'm calling
from Columbia oh hey we're in Columbia
and the capital cities were with us oh
cool my dad was just there a couple of
months ago
oh good to know yeah so I think recently
wasn't much in your show and first of
all good job on on your Cantina I'm a
watcher of yours great and yes so my
question is this let's say that Bernie
Sanders won the Democratic primary yeah
and who who do you think should be his
vice president dick no idea too early to
think about I'm trying to avoid I'm
trying to take these things one step at
a time when it was 2017 and people were
saying who should run for the Democrats
in 2020 we got a deal with 2018 first
similarly we haven't even had a single
debate yet and I think before we can
figure out who the running mate should
be we've got to at least see a couple of
debates and see where everybody is what
do you have a strong feeling who do you
think the vice presidential candidate
should be if Bernie is the nominee well
I'm torn me too
tulsi gabbard and Elizabeth Warren why
do you like that well Elizabeth Warren
because she is proposing almost the same
idea that bernie is and with that if
they are running together they can
become like on the the drinking flow
source okay and and so she gathered is
because of her international her
international policies so she is strong
in that and she can help out Bernie in
that because we
yes from what I can see in what way is
Bernie weak on international policy well
in that I'm playing nuts or I just think
that in the thing of the droning system
in the joining other countries that I
think that's that's the main problem I'm
not sure about that okay so what did
Bernie say about droning I really don't
oh man I don't know yet something
specific in mind that that's fine well
listen I think that there is going to be
plenty of time to figure out who the
right running mate is for whoever the
eventual nominee is I think you're
making the case for example with
Elizabeth Warren that because reviews
are similar to Bernie's she would be a
good pick that's one perspective the
other perspective would be you want
someone who actually differs from Bernie
another in order to appeal to more wings
of the Democratic Party
I don't know I'm sort of taking a back
seat and waiting before I take a
position on that okay good thing okay
all we've gotten from Columbia really
appreciated hope to hear from you again
okay all right great take care thank you
so much for the call